hey everyone today we're doing a video that
answers a lot of questions that we've been
getting in comments uh you might have seen
the last few videos that we released our performances
that Michael and I have done of some Baroque
repertoire and if you've heard those pieces
you've heard that Michael sings very high
using his falsetto but when he speaks come
here you speak hello he speaks normally so
why is this so we thought let's do a little
video and explain to you what is a countertenor
yeah sure so a counter tenor is above tenor
a male that would sing above uh the natural
tenor sound would be and what's the tenor
maybe some people don't know right a tenor
is going to be the highest of male voices
other than a countertenor but in speaking
register or in what we call modal voice so
what you're hearing right now chest voice
also right chest voice right exactly really
how I see it is that there are three General
parts of the voice that I use um technically
throughout my rep and that is my chest voice
followed by what I call a mix then an actual
head Voice or what a lot of people know as
a falsetto can we hear an example of each
one yeah so so a chest voice for example would
sound like as I speak or as I sing in a higher
pitch it would be foreign that idea and then
like a mixed sound would be as I get a little
bit in between those two voice types so to
be
that idea oh and then as I get higher I start
to go into what's actual head Voice or a falsetto
so it sounds like this
[Applause] whoa So within piecing all of that
together it is one voice it's not that I sing
as two different voices and I I really don't
necessarily see them as two different voice
types it's just an extension of what I do
when I was in high school I joined this this
group called the Houston grand opera High
School voice studio and in my audition for
that group we had sight reading and they played
the tonic chord for for that sight reading
to help me hear my key in this really high
pitch and I was like I guess they want me
to sing up there so I did and what ended up
happening was my teacher said have you ever
thought about singing countertenor well and
I asked the same question that probably many
of you have asked what's that and so uh in
that audition I ended up changing my life
without even knowing it because I started
this Trek of learning about early music and
learning about what a countertenor is and
who knows maybe some of you could be a countertenor
um because we all have that ability to sing
in our falsetto and so I still sing tenor
and I still sing like if I sing pop music
I'll sing as a tenor but really a lot of even
pop singers we know today are considered counter
Tenors um and so some of my favorites are
like Mitch Grassi who sings with Pentatonix
he's a natural male Alto but you also have
even people like Freddie Mercury even like
Frankie Valli from the Jersey Boys um all
right what's the one the song for that everybody
knows from Jersey Boys
it's that idea like we've all used this and
it comes from from a really a long line of
history of people liking High voices and so
everything from like Maroon 5 that we all
know to even uh the history of where where
the countercenter voice comes from which is
the castrato we're going to get into that
we can yeah there's a lot there's a lot to
say about that before we do I wanted to also
mention that like for example uh I used to
listen to a lot of 80s metal and things right
and that style a lot of people first of all
they're all super high Tenors uh and then
a lot of them end up using their falsetto
with even a wide operatic vibrato I used to
listen to a lot of Iron Maiden right and he
uses that sound all the time
uh and uh Queen's Reich and all these other
they're incredibly versatile uh singers and
actually so for me I was already familiar
with that voice type before I ever got into
early music and discovered but uh what a camera
Tanner was or even let alone what a historically
a castrato was uh so that's probably one of
the most shocking things I think we got one
funny comment on our YouTube video which is
like are you sure he's not a castrato and
so fill us in uh what is a castrato um what
are we talking about right so castrato is
uh well it was they've outlawed this practice
thankfully uh thankfully um but essentially
what would happen in 17th 16th century Italy
is that they would have these really beautiful
boy choirs and they would attract these awesome
singers and they'd come in and they would
learn from such a young age and when they
found a voice that was that was Exquisite
they would then castrate them and so that
they could keep that delicate high voice sound
that we all like and I and I think it came
from this practice of creating these Superstar
talents um and preserving this Angelic sound
like if we we've all heard like a child speak
it's such a beautiful it's a cute it's a really
nice sound and say they wanted to preserve
that right before their voice drops and they
go through that awkward cracking stage right
and eventually they can no longer sing it
so this is yeah this is a way of preserving
that beautiful boy soprano High register right
and so unfortunately these kids got really
famous like really like really famous Justin
Bieber amount of Fame and um so they were
truly the rock stars of their day and so they
would castrate thousands of children in order
to to preserve this sound but not all of them
ended up being famous I was gonna I was gonna
mention that that's kind of the the saddest
part I was thinking you know that's terrible
what they did to them but then they went on
to be super celebrity rock stars but no I
mean a small percentage of them small percentage
right right only had part of their lives ruined
you know exactly and and so those those not
to diverge too much but they would they would
be stuck in churches or in places of of work
that um that might not be great and not to
mention some of the the the uh surgeries didn't
go very well and so that's oh yeah right we're
dealing with like 17th century medicine exactly
but thankfully through that we got some of
the most Divine music in my opinion in the
world that's ever been written [Music]
[Music] so today you're singing as a countertenor
in roles and operas that were meant for castrati
right yeah they would have been written for
they actually in many of the scores have written
exactly who who would have been the castrato
so for example a very famous castrato was
named senesino and so you'll see almost every
famous role that George Frederick Handel wrote
for an alto it was written for that same guy
well yeah I've only ever heard one castrato
because there's like there's this famous recording
you can watch on YouTube I'll put it in the
description
[Music]
which is known as kind of the last Estrada
you can listen to I hear he might have been
past this Prime and it sounds a little a little
weird to listen to right but you can actually
listen to a recording around I don't know
like 1900 wait basically Recording Technology
started to capture this and so you can check
that out yeah I think just to to kind of finish
the point of the castrato into the counter
tenor why we have such a an important part
and role in in our new productions of broke
operas because these castrati would bring
in this masculinity and this kind of heroic
style uh characterizations and now we have
what was what is called Pants rolls and so
a lot of mezzo Sopranos or female presenting
characters will will come in and they'll they'll
sing castrato rules um but this this new rise
of countertender allows for uh male presenting
people to come and sing these roles and give
a little bit more of the the size and the
masculinity that might be more comparable
to what a castrato would have would have been
well when a male voice learns how to really
develop that falsetto register and craft it
and control it uh it can be a really beautiful
thing uh you know we all know it maybe you
do like a Mickey Mouse impression you know
this type of voice up here is your falsetto
but actually to learn how to hone that and
make it sound as beautiful and controlled
as Michael can it's so sweet and light and
especially we were talking about it earlier
playing with just one plucking loot or fiorbo
and that voice is such a beautiful pairing
[Music] foreign [Music]
we all have this energy in this this care
and want to hear things that are ethereal
so so there's other voice types that are also
out of the ordinary like a contralto and when
I hear like a contralto or a very low bass
sound it's just it's magnificent it's something
that you don't hear all the time and so we
get this kind of new or wow factor about it
and I think one thing that's really important
to me about that to get across about counterintenders
is that it's just an extension of your normal
voice and that everybody can do it it just
takes years and time and practice and uh care
to to create something that is really maybe
not effortless because it's not effortless
but it is it is definitely um I think it's
just a part of what I do right let's hear
an example now we want to hear the whole piece
but let's hear a little example of some of
the recordings
we made if you haven't yet heard them [Music]
foreign studying [Music]
foreign
[Music]
voice is such a beautiful sound and Michael's
in particular I'm a huge fan of your voice
so thank you for for doing all this if you
are enjoying this and you want to learn more
about counter Tenors or listen to some other
famous countertenders uh Michael who can they
listen to who would you recommend right I
think it's important to know that the Resurgence
of the countertender voice within the classical
realm didn't happen all that long ago it was
it was really started with uh the composer
Benjamin Britton who wrote who started writing
for this counterintendent named Alfred deller
oh yeah and it's an interesting sound Alfred
is um but it was he's really the the segue
into what we now know as the modern countertender
[Music] I listened to a lot of alfredeller
when I was in college I discovered him and
I thought especially for that time I think
it was to hear that to have that type of voice
in the world right showing how beautiful this
music can be uh was really important so I
I loved listening to I would strongly recommend
yeah and I would go from Alfred deller to
uh James Bowman and Russell Oberlin Arts three
of the the major uh beginnings of what we
now know as the counterintowner voice uh within
classical music and then as we started to
get later into the field um my very favorite
countertender is Andreas Shull he's a German
counter-center [Music]
gorgeous voice but some other guys that are
really taking care of this voice part is Philippe
jeruski and we have David Daniels and then
going forward from there some Modern counter
Tenors that are singing today are John Holliday
there's a new sopranist his name is kimon
Mara that I've sung with Jaco berlinski and
yeah there's so many counter centers out there
to listen to and what I love about the countercenter
voice is that every single person I've sung
with or I've met or I've listened to is different
I've really not heard two counter tennis that
sound exactly the same it's true that's a
good point and I think that's so fascinating
and everybody has their own color and maybe
we'll hear one of you guys sing sing with
a different color so please do check out all
these examples of wonderful singers that Michael
mentioned and of course our recordings that
we've made we have three videos now that we
we made that you can check out in the description
below so Michael this is a real treat thank
you so much for sharing uh with with my YouTube
audience and I can't wait to do prepare with
you soon yeah it's my pleasure man thanks
for having me on thanks and we'll see you
guys next time foreign
[Music]